quand je suis passé devant j'ai vu du
sable je me suis dit tiens faut que je
leur parle de la course sur le sable est
ce que c'est une vraie bonne idée de
courir sur les sur le sable l'été par
exemple toute l'année sur la plage eh
bien oui et non oui parce que ça fait du
bien à la tête
c'est génial il ya de beaux paysages
ensuite si on veut coin sur le sable
faut vraiment être entraînés est averti
et ça peut devenir rapidement une
mauvaise idée je vous explique pourquoi
ça n'a rien à voir avec le parterre des
sous-bois ou alors encore moins
l'asphalt parce que le sam par
définition c'est mou le sapin c'est
vraiment dur parce que la mère vient de
se retirer
tout simplement parce que votre talent
on s'enfonce beaucoup plus c'est que là
vous allez étiré toute la fibre
musculaire de vos mollets ainsi que
votants dont beaucoup plus que
d'habitude et donc le lendemain
aïe aïe aïe vous allez le sentir passer
donc si vous voulez vraiment courir sur
le sable pour vous faire plaisir
deux conseils tout d'abord vous
raccourci s'est considérablement votre
temps d'entraînement et puis ensuite
vous allez courir au plus près de l'eau
là où le sable est encore dure le sable
mou à moins d'être vraiment entraîné
averti laissé tomber à très bientôt pour
de nouveaux conseils ni